مشاهدينا نتابع هذه التفاصيل مع زميله من
جده نصفين مراسل العربيه وكان هاني حدثنا
وافادنا قبل قليل بان 1200 معتمر من
السودان مستعد للمغادره من ميناء جده
باتجاه بورتسودان وانت موجود هاني على عين
المكان فحدثنا عن التفاصيل عن الظروف كيف
هي
نعم اهلا بك واهلا بمشاهدين قناه العربيه
العربيه تواكب ايضا عمليات الاجلاء وكذلك
عمليات المغادره من هنا من تحديدا من
ميناء جده الاسلامي وكذلك عمليات الاجلال
التي تتم في قاعدتي الملك فيصل البحريه
وقاعده ايضا الملك عبد الله الجويه ولكن
تحديدا من هذه المنطقه وبداخل صاله
المغادره في ميناء جده ميناء جده الاسلامي
حيث يتم في هذه اللحظات الان استعداد اكثر
من 1200 معتمر هم يستعدون للمغادره
باتجاهنا بورتو سودان او بورتو سودان نعم
بعد انهاء اجراءاتهم وايضا انهاء
الاجراءات النهائيه
لمنصه الجوازات السعوديه طبعا
عدد على هذه السفينه تحديدا وقد يصل الى
اكثر من 2000 معتمر يغادرون لهذه لهذا
اليوم ولكن حتى هذه اللحظه العدد الذي
وصلنا اكثر من 1200 معتمر اذا ما زلنا
نرصد عمليات انهاء اجراءات المعتمرين
المغادرين من السودان باتجاه
ميناء بورتو سودان عبر المنصات انهاء
اجراءات الجوازات التي خصصتها السعوديه
طبعا هؤلاء المعتبرين قدموا في شهر رمضان
الماضي وبعد الاحداث الاخيره التي حدثت في
السودان بين طرفي النزاع قامت الجهات
المختصه السعوديه
بتوفير مقرات اماكن لهم وكذلك توفير
الوجبات اللازمه وكذلك
المقدمه لهم حتى حان الوضع المناسب الان
بحسب التقييم وبحسب ايضا رغبه هؤلاء
المعتمرين بالمغادره من هنا وامنت لهم
وامنت لهم السعوديه سفينه خاصه سوف تغادر
في مسائي هذا اليوم في تمام الساعه
الثامنه مساء اي بعد ساعه من الان على هذه
المنطقه تحديدا هي منطقه الجوازات يتم
انهاء الاجراءاتك في غضون ثلاثين ثانيه
اذا نتحدث عن ايضا الكشف او او اخذ
العلامات الحيويه عبر البصمه وكذلك
التقنيات الموفره في الجوازات السعوديه
وبعد ذلك يتوجهون مباشره الى البوابه
الخاصه كما نشاهده هناك من قبل لو يلتقطها
المصور هم يستعدون
لاخذ او التوجه الى حافلات التي سوف تقل
لهم الى السفينه الخاصه طبعا السفينه سوف
نرصدها في النشرات القادمه ولكن احببنا ان
نرصد الوضع الحالي بالنسبه للمعتمرين من
السودان اذا اخذنا لو نجري لقاء سريع مساء
الخير عليكم السلام ورحمه الله مرحبا بكم
في احد المعتمرين
متى جيت وفي اي شهر رمضان او قبل ايوه جيت
في شهر رمضان طيب بعد الاحداث اللي صارت
في السودان الان وصارت العمليه عالقه وش
الاحداث اللي صارت هناك هل تم توفير لك
سكن هل انت كنت برغبتك تسكن بالحالك اعطيه
التفاصيل ايوه انا جيت لحالي
جزاهم الله خير الناس اهل المملكه وفروا
لنا سكن وكل شيء فالحمد لله الان انت متجه
بورتو السودان
الاحداث التي سوف تواجهك ماذا تتوقع
والله عموما كده الاخبار التي وصلتنا
البلد اماني الحمد لله الطريق في اي منطقه
البلد امان في اي منطقه او في كل ولايات
السودان الطريق امن قالوا فما عدا الخرطوم
فالحمد لله ان شاء الله هنوصل اهلنا باذن
الله سالمين امنين طبعا بيستقبلكم او سوف
تستقلون حافلات هناك او كيف وسيله
المواصلات انت في اي منطقه في السودان او
في اي ولايه نحن في ولايه القضارف
فالباصات موجوده من بورسودان للقضارف
موجوده متوفره
[موسيقى]
الى ولايه ومتوفره ايوه ان شاء الله
لكن انا شفت بعض المعتمرين انه ياخذون
وجبات مجففه يعني شروها بكميات كبيره
موجوده كلش موجوده الحمد لله وامتعدنا
موجوده ما شاء الله يعني ليش ماخذين
الكميه هذه الكبيره يعني
طريقه السفر وكده
مع سلامتكم توصلون بالسلامه ان شاء الله
اذا هذا احد المعتمرين في مدينه القطارف
وسوف يتجه وهو يقول ان الطرق امنه ولكن
منطقه الخرطوم تحديدا او مدينه الخرطوم هي
ليست امنه هناك من يستقبله هناك ايضا كما
اوضح ان هناك حافلات ولديه معلومات واضحه
بالنسبه لما اخبرنا به وهذا بدليل ان هناك
تنسيق بينه وبين اقارب له او عائلته هناك
فهم يطمئنون على هذا الحال عموما منهم من
يقول الوضع هناك ازمه كبيره ومنهم من يقول
الوضع امن ولكن اهل السودان اعلم
بديار ولكن رصدناه هنا رصدنا انهم قاموا
بشراء الماكولات الخفيفه والمجففه بشكل
كبير
ونشاهد ايضا غير الحقائب الخاصه بهم هناك
بعض الصناديق
التي تم
شراء فيها بعض البضائع المجففه مثل
المكرونه او المعلبات المجففه وكان
استفسار لبعض المعتمرين لماذا هذا الامر
قالوا لا نعلم ما هو الوضع هناك الحالي
بالنسبه للازمه الغذاء وكما ايضا من خلال
التصريحات التي صرح فيها اليوم السيد
الطيب ادم وهو ممثل الامم المتحده للطفول
والذي تحدثوا لنا في داخل السودان ازمه
مياه وازمه غذاء وايضا يواجه ازمه صحيه
وهذا بحسب حديثه وهنا قد قد يكون
للمعتمرين وجهه نظر اخرى في شرائهم
واقتناهم لهذه البضائع المجففه شكرا جزيلا
لك هاني على كل ما وفيتنا به من تفاصيل
نعود لك في سياق نشرتنا القادمه هنصفيان
مراسل العربيه شكرا لك لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط
على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات